uh it is Grammy Emmy and Golden Globe
winner Queen Latifah okay yeah you'll
get your shout out oh my God you're
killing me today next year uh Queen
Latifah star of the hit CBS drama The
Equalizer the awards celebrate Black
excellence in movies TV theater music
and literature the A-list presenters
include Janelle Monae Carrie Washington
and Zendaya and Vlad
feature presenters include GTA listen we
love Queen latifus
I always love but I wouldn't mind seeing
you up there one day
uh so let me tell you when it airs the
54th double the NAACP image Awards will
Air across Paramount Global networks
including CBS bet MTV VH1 and Paramount
Network this Saturday at 8pm oh can't
wait I'll go California can't wait I
gotta work you gotta we all we all gotta
we all have to work we wanna watch
though